as now the entire multiverse is about to
come under attack
there is a malevolent force at work one
driven by a singular goal I hope your
Washington
[Music]
welcome back everyone
press f in the chat for everyone in the
air overs for all those people that died
this will be my crisis on Infinite
Earths episode 1 video there was a whole
bunch of Easter eggs a bunch of cameos
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel I'll be doing videos for
all the episodes of the crossover be
sure to subscribe to get everything
we're doing a flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the episode on the video
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet because so much
stuff happened but we'll do top 10 WTF
and Easter eggs as we go along starting
with number 10 the monitor explains the
origin of the multiverse it kind of
starts with a universe Big Bang
explainer and then how everything split
out into different universes do we get
to the modern-day multiverse he has not
fully explained the origin of the
anti-monitor yet but we just got a
teaser for that at the end of the
episode with pariah Welles the newly
minted pariah Welles formerly Nash wells
so they'll probably explain that in
episode 2 which will be tomorrow night
on Monday but number 9 all the cameos
from the actors from other DC movies and
television shows so we start with Earth
89 for the Batman 1989 movie they play
the theme song from the Batman 1989
movie and then Robert wuhl who played
Alexander Knox during that movie cameos
reading a newspaper from the Gotham
Gazette which was the newspaper he
worked for reading Batman captures Joker
headline and in the picture it's
actually Michael Keaton's version of
Batman but here's the thing when the
skies turned red and he gets really
upset and turns to look at the sky at
the back stable and says I hope you're
out there watching big guy it's not
Michael Keaton's Batman symbol it's a
different one that looks more like the
bat woman bat symbol which is kind of
weird I don't know why they did it that
way if they're going for the bat me in
1989 reference why wouldn't you just use
his Batman logo but that might have been
a licensing thing may be Warner Brothers
didn't let them use that but the weird
thing is is that he's got the correct
logo in the newspaper article if you
zoom in and look on his chest
it's Michael Keaton's classic Batman
logo so I don't know why this would be
different from the bat-signal in the sky
then we go to earth 9 and it winds up
being the Titans cameo with Jason Todd
and Hawk the funny thing about this is
if you watch the Titans finale from
season 2 Jason Todd is nowhere to be
found so apparently he was busy filming
this crossover when they were filming
their finale but you could say that this
kind of soft canonize is Titan's to them
verse of the arrow verse but obviously
they're on a very different earth so
that explains why they're not running
into each other every single week we go
back to earth X from the cross over from
a couple years ago and the ray comes
back everybody wondered when he was
gonna come back we go to earth 66 Gotham
City for the Batman in 1966 TV series
Burt Ward in real life doing a very
Robin esque line of dialogue and walking
a dog that looks a lot like ace the
bat-hound from the Batman comics we then
go to Wil Wheaton who's on supergirls
earth earth 38 foretelling the doom of
all screaming at everyone about the end
of the world and if you're wondering why
Wil Wheaton had a cameo during this it's
because he used to voice some animated
characters in the early 2000s in the DC
Universe so he has played DC characters
before the number 8 the redo on the
Superman origin scene so obviously we
meet baby John Kent Superboy this is
right out of the comics he's gonna be on
that TV show that Superman's getting on
the CW next year I don't know if he's
still gonna be a baby on that TV show
but they basically do Superman's origin
story because Argo city is gonna get
wiped by the antimatter wave so they
stick him in the only pod that's left
and fire him off of that planet just
like supergirls origin story - the pod
goes off course and gets stuck in a
temporal wormhole and winds up on old
Oliver Queen from 2046 is planet which
is earth 16 so they can go back and
visit him from that cameo during legends
of tomorrow season 1 the one-armed older
version of Oliver Queen
Superman also confirmed later that
Cara's mother played by Erica Durance
was also killed
but during episode 2 Erica Durance will
be back cameo II again as Lois Lane from
Smallville with Tom Welling Superman so
she will be back on the show this is big
thread with Oliver and Mia through the
episode because obviously she's gonna
get the spin-off TV show that's gonna
debut next year green arrow in the
Canaries I believe is the title of that
show all of his conversations with her
is basically him passing the torch
there's a lot of on-the-nose dialogue it
gets a little cringy and you kind of
tell what they're doing like oh there
should always be a green arrow because
you're getting a spin-off TV show the
reason why they had to rush that is
obviously because of the twist at the
end of the episode press F in the chat
for Oliver Queen because he wasn't going
to be around to pass the torch in
episode 2 but the number 7 Harbinger
goes around collecting all the mains
from the different shows brings them to
super girls or
this sort of gives them the business
about what's going on with the
antimatter wave it's an event that
started a long time ago and has just
taken this long to get to their version
of Earth there was one more funny cameo
that I spotted during the legends of
tomorrow seen when harbingers showed up
at the sports bar during quiz night to
pick them up the person leading quiz
night is actually Griffin Newman who you
might recognize as Arthur from Amazon's
the tick TV show but they're not trying
to canonize the tick to the arrowverse
or anything like that he was just being
a guest star in that funny role it's
just a funny coincidence that he was
also on the take TV show they have a
couple funny moments when all the heroes
show up but number 6
once Barry tells Oliver about the future
newspaper I'm supposed to die the
monitor told me that I have to Oliver
gets all pissed off cause a flag on the
play and talks to the monitor and he
gives in to the business but the monitor
tells him that the deal he made to
sacrifice his life in exchange for Barry
and Cara's only covered last year's
crossover during Elseworlds
all bets are off for a crisis on
Infinite Earths the reason why they did
that I think is for the writers to keep
the tension up otherwise you wouldn't
worry about the flash at all but really
to be honest most of the mains will have
to go back to their TV shows after
crisis not including Oliver Queen press
F in the chat one more time but there
were a couple moments at the end of the
episode especially lines of dialogue
from pariah Welles where they said
things aren't going down the way we
thought they would things are gonna be
very different
that's the writers way to say that we're
changing things from the comics so that
they won't be quite so predictable and
you won't know what's happening three
episodes before it actually happens but
there are a couple things that you can
probably assume based on what's going on
with the shows going forward the flash
will come back there'll be a back half
of the season Supergirl will still have
a backup of the season most of the
legends will come back after the
crossover because they're next season
starts right after crisis ends but they
just want you to think that it's still
possible for the flash to die during
this at some point if he does die though
he will have to be brought back to life
in some twisty way all explained the
twist with Oliver Queen though because
he's not out of the crossover completely
he will come back later in the crossover
but in a slightly different way but
number five another Oliver Queen old
Oliver Queen from 2046 they sort of give
him some closure when Sara Louis and
Brainiac go to earth sixteen in the
arrow cave to pick up John Kent so not
only is this on a different earth it's
another earth
in the future the reason why they went
to this earth was to give him some
closure because he's like the sad old
version of Oliver Queen I'm so sad
everything's terrible all my friends are
dead everything's in ruins they wanted
to give him a happy moment and let him
be a little bit cheerful feel better
about the choices that he made like oh
wow it really worked out for me in an
alternate reality before the antimatter
wave comes and wipes his version of
Earth and they poured away it was also
an else world story where a version of
Superman
after his pod left Krypton actually
landed in Gotham City and he was adopted
by the Wayne's raised as their son and
got a very Batman esque version of a
Superman origin story so you can look at
this as a small Easter Egg for that kind
of story because you have to assume that
if they had never shown up to pick up
baby John Kent then old Oliver Queen
would have raised him as his own son but
number four the battle to save the
planet you can see all the ante monitors
minions they're supposed to be shadow
demons that's the way they were
described in Nora's future newspaper I
feel like the design of them is okay but
they're just meant to be like these big
CG creatures that they can blow up on a
whim the Jumpgate that they create to
get all the people off the planet looks
remarkably like a Stargate for anybody
who's fans of the Stargate TV series but
they're also doing the towers from the
comic book so in the comic book the
monitor creates these giant towers to
stop the anti-monitor they look like
they're ripped right off the comic book
page but the funny thing is is that
Harbinger says that the monitor placed
them there at the dawn of time on all
these different planets you would think
that the Legion of super-heroes with
their 30th century technology would be
able to detect something like that
underground the city Oliver has a couple
special arrows including three the new
trick one that he uses to disable the
monitor I'm assuming that that's the one
that he was using Curtis and all the
other people to collect stuff to create
but they kind of answered the question
with the monitor being evil with the
pariah well sort of tag at the end it's
not the monitor you need to be worried
about he definitely wants to help people
it's the anti-monitor that you need to
worry about when they come back to the
arrow cave the monitor is very clear
though that billions and billions of
people died but Oliver was able to save
an extra billion people by sacrificing
himself but then number two Nash wells
shows up as the pariah character from
the comics there's all this backstory
that he brushes over really quickly
explaining how he used to be Nash wells
and a lot of that gets into the prequel
scene that I did a video for a couple
days ago
they tagged it at the end of all the
episodes in the midseason finales the
same scene of Nashville's trying to
enter the monitors place the newly
minted pariah explains that he's now
serving his penance because what he was
actually doing there was being tricked
by the anti-monitor into releasing him
from his confinement so it did confirm
my theory that when he was speaking to
this person booming voice that he bowed
down and worshiped him and he'll get
everything that he wants he was actually
speaking to the anti-monitor who just
sounds a lot like the regular monitor
I'm assuming they'll show us a version
of that backstory during episode 2 maybe
just a quick couple scenes because we've
already seen all that stuff happened
where he opens the door and is bathed in
white light but those seven symbols were
the symbols of the seven different
Paragons they'll get into all that stuff
during episode two but episode 2 will
also be there Kevin Conroy Batman cameo
it'll also be Tom Welling scammy oh and
that's will meet Kingdom Come Superman
for the first time also played by
Brandon Ralph really the biggest
surprise of the episode though was as
they let off with number one the death
of Oliver Queen press F in the chat
pulling out do whatever you want to say
your goodbyes
but you won't be gone for that long this
version of Oliver Queen definitely died
here but Stephen Amell will be back in
the crossover later as a slightly
different version of the character
there's a lot of theories that he will
become the next version of The Spectre
in the arrowverse they've already cast
Jim Corrigan who is the comic book
spectre for the crossover it's a
different actor so what might happen is
is that he gets killed by the
anti-monitor so the god of the arrow
verse multiverse needs to select and
mint a new Spectre to replace him and
that person becomes Oliver Queen who has
died but it's still open to speculation
so post all your theories in the
comments do you think that Oliver Queen
will come back later in the crossover is
a slightly different version of the
character of course I'll do a video for
episode 2 episode 3 those opposed Monday
and Tuesday night I'll try to get to all
the videos as quickly as I can my next
video tomorrow morning will be for the
new Rick and Morty episode 4 and because
of so much stuff happening I won't be
able to get to Watchmen episode 7 but
the Watchmen finale is next week so
don't worry about that everyone click
here to watch the Wonder Woman 1984
trailer at all my easter eggs a billion
more times then click here for that
prequel scene of Nashville's becoming
Raya Wells thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]